it feels amazing I'm so excited I guess  I just felt like good with it I mean I  wouldn't I wouldn't have done it if I  didn't feel good with it we want to do  well I mostly just I would like for the  fans to love it descended into giggles  quite often Dakota is quite quick to  have a giggle fit well I found the humor  in it I thought that I thought I thought  but in the book we're funny I don't  condone violence against women but I  don't think this film does either people  might be a little bit like whoa at some  plants but it's it's beautiful it's  beautiful what can you do it's a 10  million people read the book so it's a  very powerful thing and it's quite a big  statement to say that they're all stupid  everything that happens in the book and  in the movie is consensual  maybe you'll please write that when you  get home I don't know